bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre dans la
deuxième partie de l'audition de
marylise lebranchu et d'andré vallini
tout à l'heure à 15h vous avez pu
entendre la première partie de cette
audition de la ministre de la
décentralisation et du secrétaire d'état
à la réforme territoriale
tous deux ont dû répondre aux questions
très nombreuses dessinateur dans le
cadre de la préparation du projet de loi
notre nouvelle organisation territoriale
de la république
en clair la deuxième partie de la
réforme territoriale le parlement en
effet a déjà travaillé sur la première
partie de cette réforme sur la carte de
région et à partir du mois de décembre
et naïve à plancher sur la deuxième
partie de cette réforme salle qui porte
sur les nouvelles compétences des
différents niveaux des collectivités
territoriales tout de suite on prend
donc la direction de la salle médicis
questions à poser à madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre de savoir s'ils ont
une perception exacte de la situation
dans lequel se trouvent les départements
dits de la grande couronne de la région
ile de france car nous nous sommes
coincés entre le marteau et l'enclume
donc il ya une belle lommel métropole
qui va se développer qui ressemble
exactement à l'ancien département de
taille que nous avons supprimé à 50 ans
et nous nous étions dans l'ancienne
celloises alors la question est de
savoir si aujourd'hui nous devons
reconstituer la cinquante ans après ce
magnifique département avec versailles
capitale et qui nous avait permis garder
les pôles de développement intéressant
parce qu'on comprenait quand même les
élus dans notre secteur
les questions qui se posent et les
enjeux de la grande couronne qui sont
ignorés la plupart du temps où donner un
exemple logement dans l'agglomération
trois communes ont délivrer ces trois
dernières années plus de permis de
construire que paris intra muros
alors on parle des filles du logement
dont on y met immédiatement les
transports ça va ensemble qu'est ce
qu'on apprend que la future métropole
revendique la maîtrise
transports comment couper à epinay à la
limite du val d'oise et d'argenteuil
il ya une route qui sait pas où on est
le grand paris avec des moyens et où
d'autres côté vous avez le droit quand
même de végéter encore quelques dessine
y avoir des transports descend alors
nous sommes en périphérie dont nous
sommes des petits tous des petits
mammifères qui tourne autour du soleil
mais nous on a une double accélération
parce qu'entre 1 métropole et plis des
régions périphériques en pleine
évolution dans leur géographie
comment fait-on que devenons nous alors
j'imagine qu'un premier ministre qui est
des failles dans une situation un peu
comparable seulement des idées mais il
faut ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
totalement dans le brouillard alors
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
que fait-on une dernière remarque on
parle beaucoup de maintenir les
départements ruraux
à la limite nous nous demandons que nos
départements qui ne sont pas ruraux ou
que partiellement aux 120 tenu parce que
entre une région de 12 millions
d'habitants
deux millions d'habitants la métropole
et des agglomérations les agglomérations
elles vont disparaître nous avons besoin
du territoire où nous avons appris à
travailler ensemble depuis 50 ans nous
avons besoin de maintenir les
départements ou alors je ne sais pas
qu'on va travailler parce que la
proximité sera pas la région et tout
sera pas transféré aux agglomérations
alors je joins mes doléances pour que
les départements de plus d'un million
d'habitants est le même sort que les
départements ruraux
merci cher collègue monsieur botrel
merci monsieur le président au nom de la
ministre cite ministre deux questions la
première le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion d'indiquer qui pourrait y
avoir un destin différent pour les
départements selon qu'ils sont urbains
mais ça rejoint propos qu'il avait tenus
ou qu'ils soient ruraux voire même
qu'ils appartiennent
un rural profond de territoire en
déshérence en ma question est la
suivante
pourriez vous nous indiquer s'il ya une
réflexion en la matière et le cas
échéant quels sont les critères que vous
retient driller afin de classifier ces
départements dans en gros les trois
catégories que je viens de rappeler le
second point porte sur la destination
des syndicats j'ai bien entendu les
explications de madame la ministre
et je dois dire que j'en partage
l'analyse
nos territoires sont très variées nous
le voyons à travers les interventions
des uns et les autres et j'appartiens
une région comme nice connaît bien où
l'intercommunalité montrent assez
naturellement en puissance et ou en
effet la question des petits syndicats
mais je mets toujours des guillemets
quand je dis petit parce que évidemment
dit comme ça on n'entend pas les
guillemets dont simplement pour dire qu'
ils ont aussi tendance naturellement à
disparaître être absorbés par les
intercommunalités place de deuxième
point qui porte sur les autres syndicats
les syndicats dits départementaux et qui
ne sont très souvent que de nom
d'ailleurs ils sont relativement peu
nombreux je n'en connais que deux
véritablement dans le département des
côtes d'armor et à ce sujet là je
voudrais simplement rappeler qu'ils sont
l'émanation du bloc communal des
communes des intercommunalités
essentiellement donc j'ai bien entendu
que mama ministre vous prévoyez à
l'article 14 qui soit maintenue je dois
vous dire que pour avoir recueilli un
certain nombre d'échos à travers les
territoires
les élus du bloc communal souhaite qu'il
le soit donc je suis satisfait de votre
réponse et je serai vigilant pour la
suite
merci monsieur botrel le monsieur
montaugé
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre la
question économique sur déterminent
l'avenir des territoires leur dynamisme
leur capacité à accueillir et à répondre
aux besoins de leurs populations
alors madame la ministre quelle est
l'ambition du texte votre dessin
en ce qui concerne la contribution
effective des territoires ruraux et
notamment ceux de faible densité à la
création de valeur et d'emplois en lien
avec leur métropole demain plus encore
qu'aujourd'hui le système métropolitain
seront les moteurs de la croissance il
faut qu'il le soit qui joue ce rôle pour
notre pays
mais le schéma très caractère
caricatural de ma part pour être compris
consistant à des mais promet des
métropoles créatrice de valeur et des
territoires ruraux sous perfusion de
dotation sus est elle adaptée comme
l'avait évoqué pour la dgf déjà ça me
paraît devoir être être évité donc pour
ans c'est vraiment une grande question
et je fais je fais un lien avec la
question des regroupements de pci la
question du seuil démographique sur le
grand territoire et je partage tout à
fait leur marque qui a été fait par mon
collègue de la marne
moi j'ai un territoire pour faire vingt
mille on se retrouve avec un territoire
qui fait 80 km de longueur sur 30 de
large quoi voilà donc pour moi la
question n'est pas tant celle du du
seuil
ça nous permettra de faire des économies
en mutualisant ça ça fait pas de doute
mais mais que celle des des ressources
et des ressources de ces établissements
regroupés pour encore une fois faire
face aux besoins de leurs populations
c'est sur les territoires ruraux de
faible densité en particulier c'est la
question des questions qui se posent par
rapport à ce texte
merci madame pour de réponse merci cher
collègue monsieur bonhomme monsieur le
président madame la ministre
ce ministre juste un élément c'est vrai
qu'entre le texte issu de documents de
mode juin et septembre il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'évolutions malheureusement il
demeure beaucoup d'ambiguïté on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement a fait un
pas de deux et en essayant de de créer
des nouvelles
des nouvelles notions comme la clause de
solidarité tri toile qui demandent
vraiment d'être précisée d'autre part il
me semble que le la faute originelle
viennent de cette fameuse seuil de 20
mille habitants c'est vrai que pour la
plupart de ceux qui sont un territoire
10 euros je veux dire entre la montagne
et l'agglomération il ya quand même
beaucoup de départements qui sont
concernés avec des situations très
précises ce seuil est mortifère et va
créer des situations effectivement il
risque de se voir diluer le sentiment
d'appartenance de ces territoires
d'autant plus que cela ce fut un
contexte double qui n'est pas dans le
texte qui donc un contexte de
raréfaction de l'argent public avec la
baisse des dotations qui ne manquera pas
d'avoir des conséquences qui a déjà des
conséquences sur la situation financière
des départements qui fortement dégradé
les taux d'endettement les le
l'autofinancement a déjà c'est déjà
dégradées et va se poursuivre donc on va
voir des départements qui vont être en
tout cas sur le plan financier va être
affaibli et dépouillé de procédure leur
principale compétence pour n'être plus
essentiellement que comme prestataire
sociale et en dépit de la clause de tri
des territoriales qui ne mérite d'être
précisée on voit mal comment cette
architecture peuvent fonctionner donc il
ya quand même souci se soucie de deux
seuils de 20 mille habitants que je
crois que vous devriez abandonné parce
que il n'y a pas de notion opérationnel
sinon celle d sinon celle issue des
documents insee qui établissent que
c'est qu'un territoire en terme de
bassin de vie l'autre ambiguïté vient du
mode d'élection c'est pas le texte mais
le mode d'élection des conseillers
généraux a changé et d'avoir introduit
des seuils d
des circonscriptions électorales de dix
huit à vingt mille habitants alors même
que la notion de territoire et de
bassins de vie n'a pas d'opérationnalité
sur une planète orale ça va encore
couper en deux coupes et les élus on ne
peut pas dire que le mode d'élection
jusqu'à présent des conseillers généraux
n'était pas démocratique n'y avait pas
plus démocratique le mode d'élection du
conseiller général et de ce fait avec le
mode de désignation directe ça crée un
lien très fort de proximité avec la
notion de 20000 habitants ça va ça va le
coupé de son territoire qui renforçait
par la réforme du mode électoral qui a
eu lieu il ya un an
donc c'est un élément qui comptera
histoire et qui ne va pas arranger les
choses de ce point de vue est plus
aggravée par une situation financière
jeudi qu'il se dégrade et voilà donc
j'espère que vous aurez la sagesse de
revenir sur ce point là qui me paraît
essentiel sinon il ne restera plus comme
l'a dit mon collègue marc la pause et un
cierge et à la lourde ce qui vous
l'admettrez est assez étonnant de et
donne la mesure du sentiment désarroi
des élus quand les mêmes invoquée par un
groupe r d ce qui est attachée comme le
sait à la licité qui est d'éviter la
référence religieuse
merci mon cher collègue monsieur jérôme
bignon derniers intervenants présents
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
il ya un point qui n'a pas été dit dans
le sur le seuil
c'est le problème de déficit
démocratique qu'ils en prennent quand
vous êtes en zone rurale que vous avez
85 ou 90 communes dans la pièce avec 90
mère qui ont fait parfois 40 kilomètres
pour arriver qui rentre dans une salle
qui n'est pas équipé comme celle ci
comme celle dans laquelle nous sommes et
on voit bien que c'est pas des salles si
fréquentes dans l'est dans les zones
rurales
ils sont au fond de la salle il n'y a
pas nécessairement micro il je coupe le
micro vous m'entendez plus là et un
certain nombre d'entre des collègues ne
nous entende plus et donc les l'habitude
qui est prise progressivement
c'est quelqu'un qui se met au fond
disant ben on vient parce qu'il faut
venir
ils savent pas très bien ce qui se passe
il repart sans avoir très bien compris
ce qui s'était passé et ils ont pas mal
de chien je suis désolé je caricature
passé la réalité c'est la réalité que
nous vivons du jour après jour dans les
cantons ruraux
je vais revenir sur les difficultés
considérables pour les joindre
vous allez me dire mais on n'a qu'à leur
envoyer avec tout le haut débit qu'on a
les des textes des délibérations sur
leur internet le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas aller haut débit et que quand
vous avez beaucoup de communes qui soit
à 500 à 512 elles ne peuvent pas
recevoir les documents et on peut pas
les prévenir
on peut pas les prévenir que la réunion
et remise parce qu'on ne peut pas les
joindre sur leur portable
puisqu'on n'a pas la téléphonie mobile
dans les communes dont on parle là à
l'instant faut penser que la réalité de
la vie quotidienne des élus ruraux n'a
rien à voir avec la avec la projection
confond les urbains ils n'ont pas l'idée
de ce qui s'y passe
j'ai fait une suggestion à la fin de la
campagne électorale c'est que les stages
irena fasse le tour des communes rurales
de france pour comprendre de quoi il
s'agit et je suis convaincu qu'il
changerait profondément leur regard sur
notre pays
en tout cas 85 % de son territoire s'ils
avaient alors je termine sur ce point
qui est un déficit qui est grave c'est
que le résultat c'est que les
communautés de communes pour fonctionner
délègue au bureau 80% 90% des
responsabilités de la communauté de
communes
moyennant quoi on écarte de la vie
démocratique et et après on dit mais on
comprend pas pourquoi les ruraux un
sentiment d'isolement mais on est en
train de le créer là le sentiment
d'isolement
quand on fait cette taille là on
accentue on aggrave la réalité et je
voudrais dire madame le ministre sans
être insolent que je connais pas
beaucoup de communautés de communes à 80
communes qui sont traversés par des
quatre voies il y en a par hasard mais
il n'y a pas de sortie en général sur
l'a4 vous
donc ça veut dire que voilà la quatre
voies il la regarde pas c'est donc hier
donc il faut être très prudent
ce sont de petites routes qui sont de
moins en moins bien entretenues par ce
que il ya plus de sous pour entretenir
les routes les dotations pour entre
l'entretien de la voirie départementale
de catégorie iii ont baissé de 50 % en
l'espace de trois ans donc voilà c'est
cette réalité j'ai terminé avec un autre
point là je vais peut-être je vais
choquer beaucoup de mes collègues mais
je me livre quand même c'est à propos
d'eads real je ne suis pas de la
commission des lois avec beaucoup de
regrets vous le savez mais je suis à la
commission du développement durable donc
la sensibilité la responsabilité des
dréal m'intéresse moi je suis je
sûrement les dréal pose beaucoup de
questions ou aux élus ruraux à cause des
shigelles qu'ils ont à traiter mais je
pense qu'il y aurait intérêt à ce que
les préfets qui en vertu de l'article 72
derniers rallyes à alénya de la
constitution sont les patrons dans leur
département fassent leur boulot sur ce
sujet là je suis désolé moi je mais non
mais je dis que j'entends bien mais le
chef du département où le chef de la
région c'est le préfet c'est pas le réal
et si les préfets ils ne veulent pas
faire leur boulot mais faut pas qu'il
soit prêt fait rien il ya comme un vrai
problème c'est imputer la responsabilité
du fait que les dréal tentent d'exercer
leurs responsabilités
c'est au préfet de faire les arbitrages
c'est pas c'est pas le préfet il n'est
pas seulement chargée du maintien de
l'ordre
il a aussi cette responsabilité-là bien
mes chers collègues elle je vais dans un
instant donné la parole à madame le
ministre et à monsieur le ministre je
voudrais simplement dire que parmi tous
les débats qui ont été mentionnés il y
en a qui en réalité sont déjà derrière
nous
le texte du gouvernement a été déposée
sur le bureau du sénat le 18 juin et il
est très clair que le gouvernement a mis
à profit ces six mois
qui
nous aurons séparer du dépôt du texte et
de son examen en séance publique pour
écouter discuter et qui l'a notamment
sur les départements pris des positions
qui ne sont plus celles que le texte de
l'exposé des motifs et de et le contenu
du projet avait arrêté au mois de juin
le débat sur l'avenir des départements
était un débat d'anticipation en juin
c'est aujourd'hui un débat rétrospectif
chacun naturellement peut avoir son idée
et même le gouvernement sûr et ses
membres sur ce que deviendront les
départements en 2020 ou 2030
mais ça n'est pas un sujet d'actualité
le seul sujet d'actualité en ce qui
concerne les départements c'est
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont avoir à faire
demain et là dessus
évidemment nous avons un débat qui doit
déboucher sur le vote d'un texte qui ne
peut pas du point de vue du sénat être
exact mort et même qui sera très
différent de celui que nous avons
actuellement sous les yeux en tout cas
sur eux
sur ce point particulier nos collègues
plusieurs d'entre eux ont mentionné la
nécessité de transformer ce texte en
texte de décentralisation en ce qui
concerne les régions il faut en effet
sans doute que cette réforme
territoriale coïncide avec des attentes
du pays dans le domaine économique et
dans le domaine de la création d'emplois
on ne comprendrait pas après avoir dit
qu'on veut des grandes régions stratège
est compétente sur le plan économique
qu'elle n'ait aucune espèce de
responsabilité nouvelle pour ce qui
concerne la lutte contre le chômage et
la reconversion des bassins d'emploi en
difficulté sinon à quoi servirait de
faire aujourd'hui une réforme
territoriale on a là des sujets qui sont
des sujets majeurs auxquels s'ajoutent
beaucoup de questions que vous avez posé
et les membres du gouvernement qui porte
ce texte vont maintenant pouvoir y
répondre mais les réponses les plus
précises d'un véritable épreuve de
vérité savait que le débat des articles
merci mais j'ai le président
effectivement le débat du département
est derrière nous juste une
une remarque nous étions hier en
discussions avec un certain nombre de
pays européens sur les politiques
publiques et rénovation des politiques
publiques nécessaires parce que l'état
des lieux montre que nous ne sommes pas
totalement performant puisque les nous
sommes en crise donc qu'il ya quand même
un sujet qui nous interpelle tous les
italiens par exemple ont supprimé les
provinces mais viennent de créer les
airs d' initiatives territoriales sur
cette nécessité d'un échelon de
proximité est quelque chose que l'italie
vient de remettre à l'ordre du jour mais
avec à un système effectivement de
répartition de compétences et de liens
totale entre les élus et leurs
territoires qui peut qui nous
interrogent et je pense qu'on continuera
à s'interroger dans les années qui
viennent
le premier ministre a dit le changement
du cap du gouvernement sur ce sujet moi
je dis toujours il ya il ya aussi une
noblesse à changer d'avis lorsque
l'ensemble des parlementaires que vous
avez en face de vous vous démontre que
le choix que vous avez fait n'est pas le
monde de la même manière qu'ils anoblé
cela part d'un gouvernement à écouter le
sénat sur un sujet comme celui là il y
aura effectivement des positions
difficiles des moments sur lesquels nous
ne sont pas d'accord mais je redis ce
que j'ai dit en début de propos
notre objectif est bien de chercher un
maximum de rapprochement entre ce que
pense le sénat est essentiel dans cette
commission
et puis nos vos collègues pardonnez moi
je lui dis renommée nom de l'assemblée
nationale dire qu'il ya des collègues de
l'assemblée nationale qui vivent dans
des départements ruraux sans population
en dramatique situation on ne peut pas
dire que
ils ne connaissent pas les territoires
dire moi j'ai la chance aussi de vivre
dans un endroit où la communauté
d'agglomération dans laquelle j'habite
que je ne dirige plus du tout n'est pas
traversée par un 4 4 voix c'est pourquoi
je fais différence avec celle pas très
loin qui est effectivement qu'il ya une
voie rapide et il faut penser à tout
cela
nous connaissons les territoires de
france et je pense que il faut que
communément nous apprenions aussi des
difficultés d'autres types de
territoires
moi je suis attentive aujourd'hui au
milieu rural pour des tas de raisons je
reviendrai rapidement à vendre et 20 min
mais je suis aussi attentive à la lipr
richesse l'hyper pauvreté qui se
côtoient dans les grands des territoires
urbains avec des élus locaux qui
souffrent encore peut-être plus d'avoir
40 % de leur population sans activité ou
en situation de grave détresse s'est pas
non plus facile à gérer donc il faut que
nous apprenions les uns les autres des
territoires de france et je pense
qu'après cette étude et ce cheminement
nous avons conduit deschamps soit
territoire de france il n'y a plus de
sujet de suppression des départements
et je pense que le choix des régions et
du nombre de régions impliquées cet
échelon d'initiative territoriales il
faudra après se poser d'autres questions
je disais très franchement à un collègue
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale de
vos collègues parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale que le texte qu'il
a écrit pour démontrer
la portance des départements ruraux est
un texte qui montre qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui où les départements ruraux
existe la situation est dramatique
ce qui veut dire que la simple existence
du département n'a pas réglé les
problèmes et qu'il faut que nous le
prenions en compte et que nous avons
sans doute des efforts particuliers à
faire collectivement sur un certain
nombre de départements très euro en
grave difficulté peut-être un petit nom
plus petit ou équivalent de départements
urbains également grande difficulté est
que nos drive de péréquation ne suffira
pas et qu' il faut qu'on se pose aussi
en semble effectivement là l'assiette
fiscale la question de l'assiette
fiscale de moi je dis toujours le
département les débats sur les
départements quelle est ce débat c'est
qu'ils financent sa solidarité
est ce que ce sont des assiettes
fiscales territoriale effectivement très
large mais qu'on ne peut pas appeler non
plus de façon déraisonnable
est ce que c'est ce qu'ils sont des
personnes par rapport à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer de ticket modérateur
pour l'apa est ce que ce sont les
familles ce serait une double peine sur
la succession nous en sommes tous
convaincus ou est ce qu'il y a une part
de solidarité territoriaux nal pardon
imaginer je le crois et vous avez raison
monsieur savary sur le sujet ppe rsa
elle s est à re qu'on avait oublié dans
dans ce schéma que global des deux
opérations les plus en difficulté il ya
un vrai sujet parce que les départements
qui ont peu de population ne peuvent pas
être à ce point solidaire des
populations les plus en difficulté donc
ce sujet est un sujet majeur et est un
sujet non pas de débat départemental ou
rural c'est un sujet de débat national
sur le financement de la solidarité et
j'entends votre argument de l'article 40
c'est vrai que sur un certain nombre de
points nous étions d'accord
et que peut-être en amont de la
discussion fera qu'on revoie ses sujets
le financement de la solidarité sur les
établissements en particulier et je mets
de côté parce que j'utilise cet argument
comme illustration de mon propos mais
aujourd'hui la simple existence des
départements ne règle pas le problème
et si moi je demande une réforme de la
dgf et si je demande à ce qu'il y ait un
député un sénateur qui s'occupe de
l'analyse dgf aujourd'hui c'est parce
que le milieu rural ne peut pas
continuer à vivre avec une dgf qu'il est
assise que sur le bâti et la population
et que si on veut su ne pas supprimer
l'équivalent d'un département tous les
dix ans si on veut garder notre terre
agricole notre indépendance alimentaire
si on veut garder les périmètres de
captage les andes et naturel du mythe
dont nous avons tous besoin ne serait ce
que pour respirer
eh bien il faut arrêter de n'avoir comme
seul base que le bâti ce qui veut dire
que les mètres carrés précieux
industriel qu'on connaît et qui doivent
être protégés portuaire et j'en passe
doivent s'accompagner hautement des
mètres carrés précieux agricole et de
protection de nos espaces
nous avons besoin de cela pour vivre
pour se battre à partir de 2035 2040 sur
la dépendance alimentaire qui est
gravement en danger parce que le système
d'importation des protéines végétales
que je radote tout le temps va s'arrêter
bref nous avons besoin de travailler sur
une assiette des jeunes qui prennent en
compte la nécessité de protéger les
mètres carrés agricoles et les mètres
carrés des espaces dont nous avons
parfaitement besoin pour vivre et et
quand on regarde à côté la seule la
demande de solidarité est un peu la
fille l'abcès de fixation sur les
métropoles je rappelle que c'est le
sénat qui a souhaité débattre des
métropoles avec certes une autre
majorité en premier met pour bien
éclairer le sujet metropolitan mais que
les métropoles ont une responsabilité et
je cite toujours jean pierre balligand
d'instituts de la décentralisation
habitants dans un milieu très rurale est
en très très graves difficultés avec des
pourcentages de votes aux extrêmes qui
approche la majorité donc ça nous
interroge eh bien il me dit moi ce que
je demande milieu rural
la métropole c'est de loger les
étudiants et dans de bonnes conditions
de travail et sur leur mobilité
d'accompagner ceux qui vont en
alternance aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'égalité de droits des
étudiants parce qu'il ya des familles
qui ne peuvent pas payer le logement ou
le transport
donc je demande à la métropole parce que
le milieu rural ne veut pas et avec
juste raison
porter une université c'est beaucoup
trop cher y compris sur les niveaux de
bac + 3 je veux que la métropole
accueille et cette obligation la de
solidarité donc c'est vrai qu'il faut
aussi qu'on apprenne à échanger sur les
sujets je vois que monsieur mais a
retrouvé ce jeudi est idiot mais est
longtemps que ça dure donc c'est pas un
problème mais je crois que nous avons
des sujets communs entre le rural et
l'urbain qu'il faut que nous abordions
aussi y compris sur les bases fiscales
de la dgf parce que le département ne
réglera un patou dont j'entends vous
remarqué et entre temps on pourra
regarder avec marisol touraine en
particulier un certain nombre de sujets
sur lequel effectivement l'article 40
vous en remettrez je reviens au débat
général aussi vite que possible
l'abcès de fixation sur les dréal est un
abcès de fixation sur le contrôle alors
on a les aces qui posait un problème
majeur les questions de l'urbanisme
madame royal a décidé de revoir un
certain nombre de procédures d'abord pas
pour que les dren change mais pour que
nos citoyens change parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 90 % et en a qui sont bien
placés pour le savoir de projets qui ne
voient pas le jour contenus des recours
des recours des contentieux les
manifestations des recours multiples
recours avec des projets un gros projet
en termes d'urbanisme
aujourd'hui dépasse 10 ans je parle de
gros projets donc on a un vrai sujet de
procédure à réécrire de contentieux en
amont et non pas en aval bref tout ça et
est à l'oeuvre entre andré vallini et
monsieur mondon et madame royal on a un
vrai sujet essai par read real le
problème c'est nos procédures c'est nos
procédures ces normes ce et non
règlement donc là nous voulons
absolument revoir cela parce que le
fonctionnaire qui fait son travail fait
appliquer le droit
et on ne peut pas le lui reprocher mais
en revanche quand on a fait consultation
de nos fonctionnaires pour savoir
quelles seraient les simplifications
ils nous ont expliqué leur dure vie et
le fait qu' il estime que notre
réglementation n'est pas adaptée à la
réalité d'aujourd'hui et ils proposent
eux mêmes les simplifications des
réécritures je pense que sur le jeu je
crois pas que le sujet soit celui d'eads
real seulement bd direct et dréal
quelques ailes personnel doivent être
mis à disposition des régions ou bien
quel personnel rond ils ont un droit de
choix vous le savez sans doute que c'est
direct et dréal mais aussi et c'est ce
que nous essayons de faire sur la revue
des missions donc qui sera publié en
février après les 49 pressions
politiques publiques qui ont été
conduites dont 35 sont terminées et sont
lisibles sur vous pouvez demander les
documents sur ces évaluations de
politiques publiques
on se souvient de celle sur les 81
milliards actuels d'euros dépense
fiscale comprise des deux entreprises
françaises
quand on voit notre taux de chômage on a
un vrai sujet donc effectivement d'un
certain nombre d'évolutions de
politiques publiques à regarder de près
je passe le logement et bien d'autres
elles sont à votre disposition
après ces évaluations de politiques
publiques plus la revue des missions qui
sera donc publiée en février
je pense que et l'idée est retenue
d'avoir des débats sans loi mais
simplement des débats avec les
commission ad-hoc pour voir comment on
va pouvoir faire évoluer les missions de
l'état l'état va fermer un certain
nombre de milles sur inutile mais en
même temps bernard cazeneuve et j'ai
entendu le sujet en particulier du 1a de
l'article 1a je n'y reviens pas et nous
ferons ouverture mais bernard cazeneuve
travail sur l'administration
territoriale de la république que l'état
pardon et moi de la république avec
andré et donc nous pensons aujourd'hui
que l'échelon départemental est un
échelon qui a été délaissé après la
réate la réate était une bonne idée elle
n'est pas allée au bout de son objectif
elle a explosé sur le question je le dit
franchement je ne me cache derrière
aucun
aucune langue de bois elle a explosé sur
la rgpp et du coup on a remis au niveau
des régions
un certain nombre d' expertise qui sont
nécessaires sur les départements donc
nous voulons retrouver le rôle du préfet
préfet de région sur les grandes
stratégies on a besoin de lui
mais le préfet pour coordonner les
services de l'état nous avons fait
quelques études sur les dd i avec le dtm
et des délires cette notion
d'interministérialité des services y
compris à l'air départementale le
premier ministre et le ministre
l'intérieur sont convaincus avec le
président de la république que si nous
ne remettons pas de l'ingénierie sur un
certain nombre de départements nous
avons tort et enfin le dernier point qui
est à l'étude aujourd'hui c'est la
culture du contrôle nous avons besoin de
contrôler y compris parce que les
entreprises en ont besoin pour
l'exportation y compris parce que si on
n'a pas le cachet du contrôle à
l'abattoir on peut pas vendre ces
protéines animales un certain nombre de
pays nous avons une forte demande
d'organisation du contrôle sur ce sujet
en particulier pour éviter qu'on importe
n'importe quoi et qu'on exporte
malheureusement des produits qui sont de
qualité mais pas reconnu comme tel donc
on a une réécriture du contrôle à mettre
en oeuvre pour aider l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'économie comme des
territoires
et puis a regardé des procédures et vous
serez appelés si vous l'acceptez jeu
après tout il n'ya pas que la loi il ya
aussi le débat qui peut faire avancer
les choses
à débattre des propositions que l'état
aura reçu du sart vu l'émission je ferme
parce que je veux à lévis y aura-t-il un
amendement gouvernemental sur paris mais
marseille les métropoles
je vais en désordre parce que je suis
obligé de partir sur la question des
transports maritimes que nous aurions
mal géré et donc j'ai une réunion
ensuite sur la question des ports et des
transports maritimes sur lesquels
effectivement nous sommes appelés sur
paris et marseille
nous nous aurons donc un débat sur le
statut des territoires un amendement
pardonnez-moi sur le statut des
territoires
l'idée c'est de ne pas revenir à ce que
vous avez communément rejetée vous allez
rejeté un syndicat de pc paris métropole
proposent à nouveau le syndicat de pci
que vous avez
je t'ai monsieur quatelbach il a fait
allusion tout à l'heure je ne vois pas
comment le scénar reviendrait sur la
position qu'il avait prises lors de la
loi bataille puisque le sénat est à
l'origine
et c'est quand même magnifique de la
métropole du grand paris et on l'en
remercie
compte tenu des études de l' ocde compte
tenu de vos positions
compte tenu des demandes de paris
métropole il nous sommes qu'il faut deux
des droits un statut des territoires
pour qu'ils puissent gérer des
personnels et des compétences de dit des
anciennes de pci et transféré par les
métropoles les deux sujets et
développement économique le logement
transport et je réponds à ceux qui
s'inquiètent sur la grande couronne
ces deux sujets étant largement lié on
peut trouver une solution j'espère qu'on
trouvera une solution
donc je m'engage à ce que cet amendement
soit déposé naturellement avant au débat
même s'il n'est pas parfait il sera en
tout cas perfectible et nous le dépose
ont en revanche sur la grande couronne
et d'inquiétudes exprimées
nous avons voulu est tenue à ce qu'un
certain nombre de d'outils de grands
développements je pense à roissy pour
saclay je pense à marne-la-vallée je
pense à votre grand ensemble de val
d'oise qui est un des plus dynamiques
que nous connaissions en ce moment avec
ces outils que vous avez nous avons tenu
à les garder à l'extérieur il ya un
grand problème de liens de liaison
pardonnez-moi de mobilité entre les
salariés potentiels de roissy par
exemple un certain nombre de territoires
nous devons porter ce sujet nous
porterons ce sujet n'ya bien sûr dans la
cocotte unités du gouvernement précédent
qui avait raison de poser le la ligne de
grand paris express donc on ne va pas
remettre en question ce qu'ils avancent
on y a même mis quelques médias en
revanche il ya des zones comme la vôtre
dans les cales effectivement il ya des
impossibilités puisque pratiquement pour
travailler d'une commune x à roissy faut
revenir par paris pour repartir de
l'autre côté c'est aberrant donc nous
allons engager ce travail avec la grande
couronne et l'île de france dont je
rappelle qu'elle a la compétence
transport qu'elle a un outil opposable
elle est la seule aujourd'hui à la voir
et qu'il faut qu'à l'inter
lors de cet enchevêtrement
institutionnel on y voit un peu plus
clair donc on est d'accord pour avancer
là dessus non mais monsieur vias
l'évaporation des départements alors je
ne sais pas où c'est écrit peu importe
de dire que on peut se tromper sur
l'échelon mais j'ai dit je suis le
président de votre commission on va pas
discuter sur ce qui n'est plus à l'ordre
du jour en revanche vous avez raison de
poser le lien économie formation
professionnelle services post bac
enseignement supérieur recherche
votre question est tout à fait
pertinente pour dans mail pardonnez-moi
va votre question est une triste je ne
sais pas comment dire pourquoi pas avoir
l'air de vous jugez vous souvenez
monsieur y est que dans un mandat
précédent
si vous n'aviez pas été là je n'aurais
guère progresser donc je veux vous dire
que sur ce sujet là on a ouvert la porte
de l'accompagnement vers l'emploi qui
suit ce que vous allez dis je en a
prévenu le président du sénat après le
président de la commission des lois que
ce sujet est tout vert
monsieur larcher et l'ancien ministre du
travail qui a rassemblé l anpe et les
assedic
si c'est fait sinon d'idéal utt de
décentraliser les anpe et des gardes et
les assedic au niveau national
malheureusement ou heureusement moi je
ne veux pas juger du passé on a
maintenant pôle emploi et je ne sais pas
coupé pour l'emploi donc je ne coupe pas
pôle emploi et nous allons proposer
monsieur le président une
expérimentation au sens de l'article 72
de la constitution donc convention par
convention nous allons proposer cette
expérimentation je sais que de votre
côté vous allez sans doute proposer des
amendements
nous n'allons pas proposer la création
d'un nouveau service régional mais des
conventions d'objectifs et de moyens
entre l'outil et la région peut être des
mises à disposition de personnel c'était
le voeu de monsieur le président du
sénat est de monsieur le président la
commission des lois
il n'y aura pas une autorité mais
un chef de file à dans ce cas puisque il
nous faudra au moins un mandat pour voir
si tout cela fonctionne
je vous dis que les l'opposition n'a
plus forte que je que j'entends et celle
des missions locales
c'est pas l'état qui est le plus voilà
donc d'autres pistes peuvent être
explorées comme la montée en puissance
des régions aussi au conseil
d'administration de pôle emploi
ce n'est pas rien d'être présent dans un
conseil d'administration le transfert de
la tutelle des missions locales et des
maisons de l'emploi aux régions qui fait
débat mais de j'ai envie de vous dire
aussi violent que les départs de que
celui sur les départements et la fusion
des structures d'accompagnement à
l'emploi à l'échelle régionale nous
avons posé tout sur la table sommes en
phase d'expérimentation avec andré
vallini
thierry mandon le ministère de l'emploi
et pour voir comment tout ça peut
s'articuler et nous ferons propositions
mais nous attendons également des votes
dont on sait qu'elles seront forcément
pertinent n'est ce pas monsieur y ait
sur le post bac vous avez raison les bts
sont à la fois des outils très
qualifiant parfois des outils refuge une
famille qui n'a pas les moyens d'offrir
une formation longue choisi le bts donc
il faut aussi que nous fassions
attention à l'égalité des possibles pour
les jeunes mais ce sujet sur
l'enseignement supérieur est ouvert
aujourd'hui il n'est pas ouvert sur la
pédagogie et ouvert sur les contenants
part sur le contenu en revanche il est
totalement ouvert sur les transferts de
technologies des incubateurs
universitaire et du lycée créer des
centres de ressources techniques les
lycées techniques avec leur bts qu'elle
est c'est arte qui sont de merveilleux
outil de transfert donc c'est vrai que
sur ces outils-là la tutelle de la
région apparaît une tutelle
bienveillante et peut-être à écrire je
vais de plus en plus vite les uns les
autres avaient parlé de solidarité
territoriale et de périmètre des
intercoms je laisse le détail à andré
mais on a fait converger toutes les
études à la fois l'insee cgt sur le
bassin de vie
et les territoires vécus pour avoir à la
fois une interco qui fonctionne au
maximum et qui soit efficace donc
peut-être et sans doute tué reviendra un
de nos soucis
reste cette appréciation négative que
j'ai entendu et l'association des maires
de france et bien sûr l'intercours vous
étiez nombreux sur la disparition de la
commune la terre qu il est le seul moyen
à mon sens pour sauver la commune il ya
beaucoup de communes qui ne peuvent plus
répondre aux demandes de services de
leurs citoyens et je pense que
l'intercommunalité forte est le seul
moyen quand il faut qu'on soit très
précis sur ses compétences
j'ai entendu que l'intérêt communautaire
était consubstantielle de la pensée de
la mf je ne suis pas certaine que dans
tous les cas il fallait laisser le choix
c'est toujours au problème du heurt
entre le désir et le droit même si le
droit est souple même si je crois
beaucoup à la société du contrat mais
quand même sur un certain nombre de
compétences sans doute à ordonner des
choses donc le ciel de 20000 et
documenté comme dirait un certain nombre
de nos collègues mais andré y reviendra
j'ai entendu à partir de mai à mi temps
nous a quittés mais non elle est là sur
les grands enjeux les grands desseins
moi j'entends toujours ça et j'attends
comme les écrivains gelé souvent des si
vous vous avez la solution pour écrire
en trente lignes de grands desseins de
cette histoire moi je n'ai qu'un se
redresser le pays à redresser pays c'est
répondre à ce que demandent nos citoyens
aujourd'hui demande de l'emploi bien
évidemment mais ils demandent de pouvoir
vivre correctement ils sont en demande
de plus en plus de services et comment
on met en adéquation cette demande forte
la nécessité de redresser le pays c'est
à dire on défend on ne défend pas mais
le cicr est un engagement le
financièrement lourd qui nous oblige par
rapport aux dotations des collectivités
territoriales les 50 milliards
d'économies
les engagements très lourds par rapport
aux collectivités territoriales je ne
vois pas comment on aurait demandé
participation mais l'enjeu global c'est
le redressement du pays moi je crois que
tous les territoires ne sont pas
simplement des territoires de vie
des citoyens ce sont des détracteurs de
production c'est horrible de dire ça
parce que je me dégage la culture qui
est une culture empathique de l'individu
et du territoire mais c'est vrai que ce
sont des facteurs de production et
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des
territoires qui crée moins de valeur qui
ne pourraient être créés parce que les
structures ne peuvent pas répondre
on discutait et qu'un président de
conseil général récemment sur je suis à
10 heures de ma capitale régionale à 12
heures de paris et j'ai besoin moi
d'avoir une structure aéroportuaire oui
il ya quelques projets de ce type qui
doivent être accompagnés parce que sur
un certain nombre de territoires n'y a
pas d'autre solution
sauf à perdre ce territoire comme
entrant dans les facteurs de production
territoriale de la france donc oui
répondent aux inégalités territoriales
oui il ya bien sûr les la ressource mais
il ya aussi les ingénieries je reste
persuadé aujourd'hui que les territoires
les plus fragiles sont ceux où il n'y a
pas d'âme générer et on ne peut pas
répondre aux appels à projets qui sont
quand même l'écriture assez libérale
l'action publique aux manifestations
d'intérêt aux autres on a un vrai sujet
il n'y a pas de l'assistant
parlementaire peu plus tôt à cette
expression pour écrire le projet de la
petite communauté de communes orale ce
projet ne voie pas le jour
on a un vrai souci et on a un vrai
réflexion a porté et quand on crée la
solidarité territoriale
c'est avec cette idée que certains
territoires auront besoin d'une
solidarité en termes d'ingénierie
d'accompagnement et quand on parle des
services marchands
on était obligé de l'écrire pourquoi
parce que la compétence économique est
donnée aux régions
et quand on parle des services personnes
pensent multiservices on pense aux
derniers commerces d'une commune rurale
et son agence postale
on pense à ces petits outils privée donc
marchand appartenant aux secteurs
marchands qui ont besoin d'une aide et
on pense même de regroupement de deux
médecins ou de professions paramédicales
qui appartiennent au domaine libéral
d'autres secteurs marchands et qui
peuvent avoir besoin d'un soutien
donc il fallait l'écrire pour éviter
qu'à un moment donné un citoyen on
appelle en droit pour éviter ces
difficultés donc c'est pourquoi nous
l'avons écrit ce sont des outils que
vous connaissez par coeur
sur ce dessin toujours personnellement
je le redis je pense que il faut sortir
de la concurrence entre les territoires
pour arriver à une vraie coopération
moi quand j'ai défendu les routes au
niveau de la région c'était en disant
que les départs de certains départements
ne peuvent plus les porter et qu'au fond
la compétence régionale obligé à une
péréquation à la fois de fait et de
droit pour porter ces routes
si le sénat pensent différemment et
pensent différemment mais je rappelle
qu'on a une conférence territoriale du
lac sans public dans lesquels à ce
moment là il faudra parler aussi des
solidarités concernant les collèges
l'idée c'était gardons-nous au plusieurs
employeurs sur des cités scolaires
si les parlementaires pensent
majoritairement que le collège est mieux
gérée au niveau du département alors
regardons de près regardons de près et
c'est peut-être dans la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique que la
région va demander à tel département
août à l'intercours de gérer une cité
scolaire lycée collège parce qu'il ya
certaines régions qui demande et qui
vend demandait qu ils l'ont déjà exprimé
fortement à ce que certains lycées soit
aussi gérer à condition que la ressource
soit transférée par la collectivité
régionale bien entendu parler par des
départements donc il faut pas croire
qu'il espèces d'opposition qui soit
dogmatique entre les régions et les
départements
je pense que si on a fait cette
conférence et je rebondis sur ce qui a
été dit soit la clause de compétence
générale
la clause de compétence générale on la
réinstaller pendant la période
transitoire
lorsqu'on avait pas la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique vous
l'aviez supprimer sa poser un certain
nombre de problèmes y compris pour les
multiservices une aide aéroportuaire et
j'en passe donc on l'a remise dans cette
période transitoire on peut l'enlever à
nouveau parce que on a cette conférence
territoriale de l'action publique et
qu'on a créé la clause de solidarité
territoriale qui évite harcourt
destructeur dont on n'a pas besoin sur
les départements je crois que je vais
arrêter là parce que j'ai cette réunion
et sur les transports maritimes et et
commencer je vais demander
andré de continuer y compris sur la
responsabilité concernant les fonds
structurels et des choses de ce type où
je dis juste sur les fonds structurels
si tu veux on revient de la réunion avec
la commissaire il ya dix jours nous
avons écrit la responsabilité parce que
la gestion des fonds structurels étant
confiée à nos conseils régionaux
désormais la responsabilité en cas de
manquement doit être porté par celui qui
gère les fonds structurels
donc c'est bien pour le transfert de la
gestion des fonds structurels que nous
avons écrit que l'état ne portera pas
les pénalités si une région n'est pas à
la hauteur de ce qu'on lui demande
d'être ou si elle fait des erreurs en
revanche bien sûr sur la part est fait
ce qui peut être utilisée par exemple
pour des entreprises intermédiaires pour
des actions d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi d'un certain nombre de jeunes
chômeurs l'état restera responsable
parce que ça ceux contractualisés
je pense que nous éviterons et
contentieuses inutile avec la commission
et je demande si je veux bien andré de
continuer pour j'allais m'occuper des
ports et des transports maritimes
madame la ministre merci du temps que
vous nous avez consacré de la précision
de vos réponses et effectivement donc
monsieur le ministre si vous voulez bien
compléter un certain nombre de réponses
sur les peaux qui restent en suspens oui
donc sur les les entreprises de services
non marchands monsieur savary vient
d'avoir la réponse il y à une question
sur l'homme la certification des comptes
des grandes collectivités territoriales
dans les produits de fonctionnement sont
supérieurs à 200 millions d'euros
il s'agit donc quand on certifie les
comptes de visait à assurer leur
régularité leur sincérité leur fidélité
il y a des réticences c'est vrai de la
part des collectivités locales et de
leurs élus à s'engager dans un
dispositif perçu comme
suspicieux d'abord et puis surtout comme
lourd et coûteux en fait le dispositif
qui est proposé est facultatif
facultatif
il ne concerne que les comptes et que
les collectivités dont les produits
jours répète de fonctionnement sont
supérieurs à 200 millions d'euros
il est protecteur pour ces collectivités
parce que la convention précise le champ
le référentiel et les moyens avec à vis
des ministres compétents
il est progressif un bilan intermédiaire
sera fait à trois ans et définitif à 8
ans pour les collectivités qui se seront
portées candidates et volontaire à cette
certification
je reviens d'un mousse sur les finances
et la dgf la cvae aussi puisque
lorsqu'on parle des finances notamment
seront nécessaires aux régions pour
exercer leurs nouvelles compétences
on évoque immédiatement et c'est normal
la cvae tout ça sera en débat dès
l'année prochaine dès les mois qui
viennent dans le cas de la préparation
du plf 2016 et sa rejoindra la réflexion
que nous aurons qui est lié évidemment
sur la réforme de la dgf dont je parlais
avant-hier à la tribune lors de la
discussion budgétaire 2 du plf 2015 il
faut absolument réformer globalement la
dgf la rendre plus lisible plus simple
et plus équitable notamment à l'égard du
milieu rural et il faudra faire des
transferts de fiscalité sans doute des
départements vers les régions en termes
de cvae étant précisé que tout ça
devrait être adapté aux compétences qui
resteront exercée par un département et
une nouvelle compétence qui seront
confiées aux régions je pointe
d'ailleurs
chez les présidents de régions une
petite contradiction dans le fait qu' il
ne soit pas forcément beaucoup de
transferts de compétences à part
l'économie mais beaucoup de transferts
tcv eux et moi je réponds chaque fois au
président de région vous ne pouvez pas
demander beaucoup de cvae
si vous dites par avance que rouge vous
refuser toutes les compétences qu'on
voudrait éventuellement vous transférez
donc le débat aura lieu bien sûr avec
les associations d'élus au sein du
comité des finances locales et d'abord
au sénat et dans votre commission sur
les communes moi je partage évidemment
ce qu'a dit marylise lebranchu la seule
façon de sauver les communes françaises
c'est l'intercommunalité
elles l'ont bien compris d'ailleurs
depuis 20 ans on a assisté un nouveau
considérable une révolution silencieuse
sur nos territoires qui continuent
d'ailleurs un j'ai des chiffres ici au
1er janvier 2013 depuis la loi de 2010
au 1er janvier 2013 200 mouvements
avaient lieu de fusion rattachement de
communes isolées et au 1er janvier 2014
on était à 3 cents en deux ans nous
avons connu une diminution de 2600 à
2150 intercommunalités 2600 à 2100 en
deux ans c'est énorme
donc la révolution silencieuse
s'accélère en plus et la loi 2010 a eu
un effet bénéfique
notre volonté d'aller encore plus loin
pas forcément très vite mais en tout cas
un peu plus loin et même beaucoup plus
loin pour certains puisque vingt mille
habitants paraît un seuil très élevé
la plupart d'entre vous l'ont dit ce
seuil pour être s'il est retenu par le
législateur il pourrait être évidemment
abaissé par des dérogations nombreuses
qu'on pourra comment dire dont on pourra
multiplier les critères démographiques
géographiques kilométrique et c'est
maintenant si le législateur soit
abaissé ce seuil on est prêts bien sûr
et réfléchir certains parmi vous
souhaite même le supprimer totalement
il faut faire attention quand il n'y a
plus de seuil les choses bougent moins
vite lorsqu'il ya un seuil avec des
dérogations ça oblige quand même à
réfléchir à se poser des questions la
vraie question que beaucoup se posent et
moi je la ressens sur mon territoire
comme on dit et dans toute la france
parce que je circule beaucoup c'est que
les élus nous disent on a déjà dû bouger
depuis la loi de 2010 pour monter à plus
de 5000 pour ceux qui étaient en dessous
on a dû redécouper les contours ça n'est
pas le même sujet mais c'est quand même
un sujet connexe et vous nous remettez
en chantier une carte intercommunale
j'entends tout ça bien sûr
donc on va en débattre et le sénat
donnera évidemment un avis très
circonstancié très très autorisée est
très écoutée monsieur prison mézard sur
ces questions toujours je reviens aux
communes
j'ai un exemple à vous citer du conseil
général de l'isère où nous débattions il
ya quinze jours de la répartition de
subventions
je ne citerai pas le nom de la commune
même si le maire ne le prendrais pas
forcément mal l a89 habitants elle s'est
lancée dans un projet très modeste à
l'échelle du département très important
pour elle de rénovation de sa salle des
fêtes
elle est subventionnée pour ce projet à
90 % par l'europe la région le
département la communauté de communes et
il manque 10 % oui et manque et il
manque 10 % et elle ne les a pas et le
maire de cette commune où demande
financer les 10%
mais oui mais ça existe encore alors
c'est vous dire si on peut se poser la
question de la justification à ce jour
deux communes de cette importance et si
vous dire si la ppl a proposé aux doigts
pélissard et celle de madame pires bonne
et bienvenue sont bienvenues dans
beaucoup de départements et là encore ça
bouge énormément
ces deux textes la future locke donc
vous avez adopté hier matin en
commission des lois je crois qu'ils
viennent bientôt en décembre au sénat
cette loi suscite beaucoup d'intérêt
beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt dans mon
département j'en suis à près d'une
dizaine de fusion qui sont envisagées
sur les compétences des départements et
des régions d'abord sur les départements
si on reprend le texte de ce qu'a dit
manuel valls en avril 2002 cette année
il annonçait que le débat allait
s'ouvrir d'ici 2021 sur l'avenir des
départements
il a ajouté moi même manuel valls je
suis favorable à leur suppression
mais je propose d'engager le débat ait
jamais annoncé la suppression des
départements avec une date couperet
jamais il a dit que lui était favorable
et qu'il fallait qu'on y réfléchisse
d'ici 2021
en tout cas tous est derrière nous ce
qu'il faut savoir maintenant c'est que
on va de plus en plus vert et se heurte
beaucoup les cartésiens que nous sommes
je vais pas dire jacobins mais on peut
être girondins et cartésien et cartésien
que nous sommes sont habitués à un
jardin à la française en termes
d'administration territoriale de la
république
voilà et on sait bien que ce modèle
n'est plus des plus celui qui convient
aujourd'hui et en disant cela je réponds
1 à jean pierre sueur qui demandait quel
est votre dessin votre grand dessein mai
on peut avoir un grand dessin et une
ambition modeste le grand dessein parce
que c'est un grand dessin c'est d'être
utile aux territoires d'être utile aux
collectivités territoriales à remplir le
mieux possible les missions difficiles
qui sont les leurs alors voilà c'est une
loi qui a évolué au fil des mois
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement à
écouter le parlement et les associations
d'élus
c'est une loi qui donne des outils aux
régions aux départements aux
intercommunalités pour rendre les
meilleurs services publics aux citoyens
et aux usagers qui sont on le sait de
plus en plus exigeants et je crois que
ce qui caractérise notre démarche dans
la poursuite de ce grand dessein d'être
utile aux collectivités territoriales
c'est le pragmatisme
la france n'a plus besoin d'être
administrés de la même façon de lille à
perpignan ou de la bretagne à l'alsace
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
collectivité à statut particulier que
souhaite créer les savoyards ça pose un
problème parce que au moment où l'on
renforce les régions et la future grande
région auvergne rhône-alpes notamment
sur le plan économique il serait dommage
que une partie importante de cette
région une partie importante sur le plan
économique les deux savoie face à
quelque sorte est entre guillemets
sécession puisque dans cette
collectivité à statut particulier les
serveurs voudrait évident d'être le
développement économique
donc il ya un vrai souci on en parle
avec les présidents des deux
départements
mais il faut évidemment il faut
évidemment adapté l'administration
territoriale de la république aux
différents territoires de la république
et je renvoie pour terminer un rapport
passionnant que vous connaissez mieux
que quiconque que le rapport du sénateur
alain bertrand sur l'hyper ruralité
notamment sur le rôle des conseillers
généraux et sur la taille des
intercommunalités
le sénateur alain bertrand que j'ai reçu
il ya quelques jours avec qui j'ai passé
une heure et demie formidables parce
qu'en plus il est très sympathique
le sénateur bertrand dit à quel point le
sénateur alain bertrand dit à quel point
il est important notamment en milieu
rural d'avoir des intercommunalités de
taille suffisante pour avoir de
l'ingénierie pour avoir un dgs
pour pouvoir rendre des services à la
population comment 40000 non non non
mais pas en milieu rural c'est pas
possible il vous dit que 20000 c'est
déjà trop alors si non mais le sénateur
bertrand sénateur de la lozère s'il ya
un département rural c'est bien celui ci
lui considère qu' il ne faut pas avoir
des intercommunalités trop petit sinon
elles ne pourront pas faire ce qu'on
attend d'elle voilà monsieur le
président de la commission et lorsque je
voulais vous dire
pour compléter ce qu'avait dit marylise
lebranchu merci monsieur le ministre
nous avons été très sensibles au fait
que vous-même et madame angle lebranchu
et pris le temps de nous écouter et de
nous répondre je remercie également tous
les collègues qui se sont mobilisés
nombreux à jeudi matin pour venir
participer à cet échange
voilà pour cette audition en commune de
marylise lebranchu et d'andré vallini
respectivement ministre de la
décentralisation et secrétaire d'état à
la réforme territoriale
tous les deux ont donc été auditionné
par les sénateurs venus très nombreux ce
matin à propos du projet de loi à notre
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république vous avez pu l'entendre s'ils
ont pris le temps de répondre à toutes
les questions des sénateurs
eh bien ils ne sont pas parvenus à faire
taire leurs inquiétudes et sont restés
relativement flou sur les grandes
interrogations de ce projet de loi que
ce soit sur l'avenir des conseils
départementaux et plus largement
l'avenir des départements ou encore le
seuil des intercommunalités fixer ou non
à vingt mille habitants
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire à 19h pour 24 ans senna le
journal on reparlera bien sûr de la
réforme territoriale très bonne fin de
journée sur les chaînes parlementaires